hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
going to be my Constantine episode 12
video we only have one episode left next
week is going to be the finale so I'll
try to explain what's going on with the
series there's been a lot of talk about
it maybe going to sci-fi it just they
might move the show there and change the
name to help laser which I actually
think is a pretty good idea first things
first though careful for spoilers from
the episode if you haven't seen it yet
starting with top 5 moments number 5
throwing away second chances the diamond
charts in the episode those evil shards
making people Hulk out we're seeking
hosts that we're throwing away second
chances really it was dr. Gailen that
was behind it all but he was seeking out
people using the shards both the initial
victims were real app statics then Zed
almost became the next in the line of
victims when she throws away a chance to
get that tumor removed if you're
confused all the shards were part of the
same diamond a diamond that had
fractured when the doctor was fighting
in Afghanistan in the military an
explosion caused a fragment one of the
shards to get embedded inside him that's
what made him go crazy although I'm sure
he probably would had post-traumatic
stress to begin with so he might have
been a little crazy before the shard
made him evil it was a really well done
tragic character story arc because the
doctors a healer he wants to help people
but he wants to punish people who were
throwing away second chances he's not
killing them because it makes him feel
good that's why I think Manny was able
to rapture him if he had been straight
up evil then he would have gone to hell
it provided a lot of opportunities for
the dangerous habits storyline that's
that in the hellblazer comics they just
work Constantine is slowly dying because
of cancer he ends up throwing away like
second third fourth chances it's part of
the character though that he plays it
really fast and loose with his life and
the lives of others there's even this
awesome swampthing moment from issue
number nine where Swamp Thing
reconstitutes himself while Constantine
is rolling a cigarette just to give him
a warning moving on to number four
Constantine traps Manny on earth I
actually expected this to play out way
sooner and be a much bigger deal than it
ended up being I was kind of hoping he'd
spend the entire season being trapped in
a human body Manny is based on a
character Early's I think he's based on
the character Gabriel from the comics
he's someone that God makes watch over
Constantine so he kind of haunts
Constantine in a very passive aggressive
way Constantine ends up taking advantage
of him getting him trapped in a human
body on earth it's all part of his plan
to fight the demon Newark also
Constantine's trying to do a good thing
but ends up taking advantage of a friend
that through line works a little bit
better when you look at the Zed
storyline Constantine making her think
that she needs to keep going even though
it's gonna kill her the Manny stuff in
the episode was mostly used for comedy
but it was some of the best Harold
Perrineau I've seen all season we
actually we needed scenes like this way
early on him getting a [ __ ] in the
closet that I mean that was funny it was
a little on the nose so to speak but I
mean I understand why they did it moving
on to number three Zed has a tumor
that's probably gonna kill her whenever
she landed in the hospital and they were
looking at her scans there's so many
Arnold Schwarzenegger jokes on Twitter
but said in dr. Galen's storylines were
two of the strongest in the episode so
they did a really good job of telling
Zeds art from start to finish she has a
gift but it's slowly killing her it
seems like she's always had her
abilities so the tumor might be
something from more recent events like
the rising darkness or whatever mojo the
Brujeria or weaving or maybe the tumors
always been growing and it's just been
too small to notice until now it's
better to think about Zed prioritizing
her mission over her life especially now
that she thinks her abilities are from
God isn't it funny how manny stepped
around that question he gave her the
most non answer that he could possibly
give her where do you think it comes
from that's usually where you see
someone gets slapped in the face like I
asked you for an answer you're an angel
you're supposed to know everything you
guys can let me know if you agree but I
feel like she made the right choice if
she had the tumor removed one there be
no story and two if you ever watched
like any other medical drama TV show
half the people that get operated on die
on the surgery table from complications
so she might have died either way so if
you know you're gonna die you might as
well go out in a blaze of glory using
your special powers just in case you
guys haven't read dead storyline in the
comics I'm going to explain it just a
little bit so careful for spoilers for
the hellblazer comics what they're doing
on the TV shows a little bit different
but I'm gonna still put up the spoiler
tag for just a sec so Zed storyline is
the resurrection crusade storyline it
has very little to do with the rising
darkness at least in the comics she ends
up dying from complications from the
procedure they basically they're trying
to use her as the vessel for the second
coming of Christ and it goes wrong it
just it doesn't work here's what I think
the show is going to do I still think
that they're going to sacrifice her at
the end that doesn't mean that they're
going to completely get rid of
angelica celaya the actress from the TV
show they're not going to completely cut
her out of the show if they do move to
sci fi in season two what I'd like to
see is gozi just haunting Constantine in
a really passive way one of the most fun
things about the hellblazer series is
that it is multi-dimensional meaning the
characters interact with other
characters on all planes of existence
just remember Constantine looking at
Gary Lester in the mirror I mean that's
old footage of a scene spliced in but
you get the point they can still have
dead people on the show let me know if
you agree with that though if they do
kill Zed off in the finale or she dies
as part of this rising darkness
storyline do you want to see her come
back as a ghost moving on to number two
Constantine uses friends again makes
Chaz eat a shard well maybe not
literally eat a shard but you get the
idea he just throwing Chaz under the bus
they even use him to get into the
hospital by stabbing him and then
causing a distraction by making him
spray blood all over the place normally
this would come back to bite Constantine
in the ass jazz seemed like he kind of
enjoyed what was going on like he
reluctantly accepted it so I don't think
he's going to turn on Constantine
anytime soon but a really big part of
the John Constantine character is that
he abuses the trust of other people
habitually just to talk a little bit
about the visual effects though like
with these shards it was actually really
good Constantine is a show I don't think
it has a lot of money for visual effects
but they do a lot with very little like
when they're inside the layer said I
feel like the way that they've shot the
layer and the last couple of episodes
has been so interesting I'm actually a
little upset that they don't spend more
time exploring in there moving on to
number one Constantine explains that he
just sees all of his friends is already
being dead super dark and probably
foreshadowing for the finale one of my
big takeaways from their conversation is
the idea that their outcome is
inevitable in a bad way like the way
they said it made it sound like oh yeah
this is inevitable everyone's going to
die there are a couple different
versions of this depending on which
character you're looking at so so when
we have like the overarching plot the
Brujeria merging hell with earth then
from Zeds perspective you have the tumor
killing her just straight up coming over
Oh simple there and then from
Constantine's perspective the inevitable
outcome is that the demon will possess
him again or he'll turn into dark
Constantine if there's any twist on this
that I'd like to see it would be
Constantine selling his soul again or
making
bargain to try and save everyone or stop
the Brujeria becoming dark Constantine
as a way to try and save everyone and a
lot of you were wondering after episode
9 up to the end when Constantine's
looking into camera and it seems like
he's just lying and the demon might
really still be inside him I feel like
that's going to come back if you
remember all the way back to the
beginning of the series we saw the
version of dark Constantine he's like
this is your future this is what's going
to be coming you there been a lot of
times in the comics when Constantine is
either been possessed or he's been stuck
in Hell outright here's my big question
for you guys though what do you think is
going to happen in the finale to tie up
this Brujeria rising darkness storyline
or do you think that they're not going
to tie it up it seems like the only way
they have to resolve all these running
storylines is to tie everything to a
singular person then have the group
defeat set person in the comics there is
like a big bag that Constantine fights
in one of his first stories that's the
demon Newark all but Zeds father is also
someone the TV show has been pushing as
a big villainous character so just be on
the lookout for any possible connection
between saids father and the Brujeria so
I think we're all hoping the Constantine
does get renewed the show has a lot of
potential but I feel like there are a
couple issues that it needs to address
in order to kind of you know break that
barrier and become just as popular as
arrow the flash all the other TV shows
if you guys are like me and you watch
like way too much TV you start to notice
a lot of things that the really
successful shows have in common so one
you need a strong villain like a clear
villain you can point that to root
against they need to be on a character
arc that flows from the main character's
story arc it also helps a lot if the
villain has a really deep relationship
with the hero just looking at
Constantine right now I mean can anyone
tell me who the main villain is and what
their face looks like what's the name of
the actor that plays the main villain
usually if if you make it halfway
through a series and you don't know who
that person is you have a big problem
usually it's that mid-season finale
that's when you want to find out the
mid-season valley like this is the big
bad this year moving on to number two so
the hero can't start out being the
villain you really like when you first
meet a character for the first time you
really want to believe in their good
intentions before they go super dark and
they break your trust Breaking Bad is
probably the perfect example of this
where someone starts out as a very
sympathetic hero and by the very end by
thought final season turns into the
biggest villain
in my last little bit number three don't
water down the most fun things about the
series so what's the most fun thing
about Constantine right now well the
inside of the lair and all the magical
artifacts I totally get why you can't
start off with Constantine wearing the
helmet of fate or wielding the books of
magic you have to work your way up to
that but learning about those things are
really where the exciting adventure
comes from like supernatural Indiana
Jones like the librarians you know a
totally different TV show them hunting
down artifacts let me know what you guys
think though you know what are a couple
things that Constantine might be able to
fix that would make the show more
popular or make it more fun to watch
this is a side note kind of along those
lines if they do get a season 2 and I
really do hope they get a season 2 I
think it'd be a lot of fun if they did
the rise of the Trinity of sin I think
it'd be a really fun way to introduce
some more really strong characters that
could exist on their own you know
without Constantine being around all the
time like the Zed character right now
Frances she's an interesting character
but I feel like she doesn't work when
she's not with Constantine so just big
reminders next week is the finale be
sure to subscribe to get my video I
think NBC is going to say what's
happening with the show before then or
at least in the next two weeks tomorrow
Walking Dead comes back and there's
going to be a game of throne special so
I'll tree get both those videos out
tomorrow night well you guys wait for
that to drop you can click here to catch
up on air on the flash and you can click
here to get ready for Game of Thrones
tomorrow thank you so much for watching
so let's all high five let's try and
save Constantine we're almost there we
might get it we might see season two
you